sound of Freedom has been one of the
biggest film surprises in recent memory
and although the mainstream media has
ceased talking about it its message is
too important for us to stop talking
about
as of last weekend it's still among the
highest grossing films in America
and has made more than 155 million
dollars in one month
outpacing Mission Impossible
in the background of all of this success
the mainstream media kept telling us
that sound of Freedom was based on a
wacky conspiracy theory full of Q
anon-based Concepts watch
it has the backing of not just
Republicans and religious conservatives
not just Ted Cruz and Elon Musk but also
Q Anon folks and the internet tinfoil
hat Brigade these films are created out
of moral panics they're created out of
bogus statistics they're created out of
fear and with something like sound of
Freedom it specifically is looking at
keyword on concepts of these child
trafficking rings that are run by the
high-level Elites
bogus
they want us to believe them it ignored
the real news and real travesty that
sound of Freedom aims to spotlight
in the wake of those on the left telling
us that child trafficking is a
conspiracy they occasionally take a
break to report the truth the
Inconvenient Truth
this courtesy of NBC News
the FBI found 200 sex trafficking
victims and more than 125 suspects
during a two-week child exploitation
operation in July
Federal officials said on Tuesday
wait can this report be right wasn't
this all a giant conspiracy
so in the same month that sound of
Freedom was released our own FBI
simultaneously found 200 sex trafficking
victims in America
not a foreign country
right here at home
this topic remains a Gravely serious and
sick problem
and there's no one better to talk on
this subject than Tim Ballard on whom
the sound of freedom is based and Tim
Ballard joins us now he's a senior
advisor at the spear fund Tim thank you
for what you're doing thank you for your
story for for creating a movement that's
showcasing what is a sick and ongoing
problem when you hear 200 and 125
suspects I I got to believe you're
saying that's just the tip of the
iceberg here
absolutely it's the tip of the iceberg
the irony here I don't even know how to
describe it uh that the mainstream left
this kind of media is pretending it's
not happening but then saying it is
happening even more ironic than that is
the fact that all of those networks CNN
NBC MSNBC CBS Rolling Stone all of those
that are disparaging sound of Freedom
they all did reports back in 2014 when
the actual operation you see depicted in
the film happened and they gave glowing
reports it was real then ten years later
it's no longer real these same Outlets
are now saying Q Anon here's the here's
the funny part of this Q Anon wasn't
even invented until years after this
film was done it's been on the Shelf so
it's impossible that any qn you know
ideas are even in this film and anyone
who watches it knows nonsense there's
this is based on a true story it's
totally absurd help me out I gotta ask
the obvious question which is why why
the about face why not admit it why not
attack it why not get rid of it why not
promote sound effect freedom and say
this is horrific let's get rid of it why
I think I know the answer because
there's a conversation about children
that they don't want to have these same
networks are promoting this idea that
pedophiles should be called minor
attractive persons it should be
normalized the UN just put out a report
two months ago saying that maybe we
shouldn't criminalize sex with children
they don't want to talk about 85 000
unaccompanied minors under the Biden
Administration that were let into the
United States without any background
checks being done and delivered to
anyone including potential traffickers
these are the conversations they don't
want to have and they have to discredit
some of freedom because they know the
center of freedom is going to shine a
light on this darkness and we're not
going to stop we will shove this
conversation down their throats to
protect children you certainly have and
Tim you just kind of alluded to it to
add to the frustration about this
worldwide sex trafficking problem Fox
recently reported this that quote
Florida's officials said Wednesday that
nearly 40 percent of the people arrested
in one part of the state in recent
operation cracking down on child's
exploit exploitation or in the U.S
illegally so the open border on the
south is making this problem actually
worse and they have to know that
it's making it worse and here's here's
the other piece of this you need to know
the sponsors that the children come
across with a name and a number
um and Health and Human Services has to
call that number it doesn't matter who
it is in many cases it's actually
illegal immigrants who are receiving the
phone call and receiving the children
it's literally more difficult to adopt a
cat from a shelter than it is for an
illegal person or any person in the U.S
to go down and take a child out of the
custody of Health and Human Services in
fact your taxpayer dollars are now
paying for the last leg of what might be
a child trafficking experience this is
the reality this Administration is
complicit yes wittingly or not in
traveling children and then and then
they look Us in the eye and tell us it's
all Humane uh it's sick that's wrong and
it's it's a sin thank you Tim for
everything you're doing congrats on the
film
thank you sir thank you